so john yes sir you're you're this uh
you know you mentioned you told us a
story about being at this party with
nancy pelosi
i'm i'm just wondering you're here
you're speaking out you seem rather
fearless on these issues but
are there ramifications
to being in mainstream us entertainment
and challenging the establishment smack
talking them
as we say in the country does a bare
[ __ ] in the woods right
that's a big west virginia saying as
well yeah
yeah you know what happened with me was
is i was becoming that guy that would
yell at the tv
but then i would go out at the industry
events a red carpet an interview
whatever
and understand that the majority of
people running our industry were
absolutely hated people that thought
like i think
and so i would just shut my mouth bite
your tongue don't say it in here and
just go back home and yell at the tv
again and at some point i felt like i
was i was sacrificing my integrity
sacrifice sacrificing my freedom of
speech why do we have these things
because hundreds of thousands of
americans have died and bled and
sacrificed and did whatever it took to
keep those freedoms alive that's why the
lines are coming into the country and
there's no lines going out because we
have those freedoms and i'm gonna sit
here and not say what's on my mind and
speak what i know to be true because i'm
afraid somebody's not gonna give me an
award or somebody's not gonna play my
song at the radio station or whatever
yeah that's the penalty but which one is
bigger the founding fathers are walking
out there going hey give me liberty or
give me death that was not a bumper
sticker that was not a hashtag that's
what it took to get this country up and
running and if they ever found those
guys that signed the declaration of
independence they ever found them they
were going to hang them from a tree burn
their houses kill their families and
erase them from the memory of the earth
but now we're worried about somebody
throwing us off of twitter or somebody
calling us a bad name or in my case the
the music industry not giving me
everything that i want to get out of it
at some point make a call decide what's
actually important to you is your
freedom of speech more valuable to you
than the approval of the music industry
that's where i got to go
got two little boys growing up and
they're watching me
and what if i'm dealing with this what
are they gonna be looking at in about 15
or 20 years so i'm the only example they
have what did pop do when he ran into
that when the government did this or
tech did that or businesses did this
what did dad do did he just yell at the
tv and then go play ball
or did he actually say what he felt was
he the same guy all the time 24 7. did
he take his hits hell yeah and he got
scars and lost money and lost lost
popularity with a lot of people but what
did he gain self-respect integrity and
he sleeps okay at night not like dad
good for you that's why i do it like
that so here so here's my question for
you
tremendous respect for all of that do
you fear you know they'll try to come
after your kids or you might put your
kids at home they better fear ever
coming after my kids
i love it because i'll let you i'll let
you get a very good answer i'll let you
i'll let you come after me all you want
to you you leave my family alone we will
die for our families
we'll die we'll we if you said john you
were them snap your fingers and take me
out of here i mean right now we as my
daddy would say who's a quasi
pentecostal style prison preacher that i
would charge hell wearing my gasoline
suit with my water pistol blazing if you
ever jack with my family and that's what
they don't understand in this country
these liberals and people running our
country that there there is a fierce
and dedication and responsibility that
we have as parents that you step over
that line and you start messing with my
kids there is no there is no boundaries
anymore between us you want full contact
sport you want to raise the stakes on
what you're doing to our kids and how
you're in my opinion assaulting them in
all these ways you're going to assault
my kids once you try to assault me one
time i'm going to step in front of these
little kids now you're going to deal
with it with a grown-ass man and a
grown-ass woman who got nothing to lose
and don't care what you have to think
about it this is where america is going
whatever look i have in my eye right now
because i know because i know what i'm
saying i'm feeling it down in my guts
that is what tens of millions if not
more americans are feeling right now
regardless of their politics regardless
of who they voted for or what they think
about trump or biden you mess with our
kids you've got a world of hurt coming
your way this fall they're messing with
kids good for you man you've got you
know these these these teachers now
bragging on social media about how they
want to talk about their sex lives with
children and this it's the weirdest
thing to me that they're trying to
normalize the idea that five six seven
and eight year olds
are talking to the p to their teachers
about their teachers marriages or
relationships
that never happened for me when i was in
those grades because florida is where
the big conversation started the printer
writes an education bill uh when i was
five i remember the names of all my
teachers actually i remember the name of
my second grade teacher i'm sure someone
my family does but i remember these
teachers i had no idea who they were
married to i had no idea what they were
doing i was five i was eight i was nine
when i was 12 or 13
i learned about my teacher got married
that's all i learned she was out one day
a substitute came in why oh she got
married oh
they didn't come into the classroom and
say i want to tell you all about my
relationship with my husband in our
honeymoon never happened yet now this is
what they're saying oh but it's totally
normal i need to explain to these kids
like what it means
well you don't i mean first of all the
parents can
and this can be handled during normal
sex at ed if the parents think that's
what the school should be doing
but they're actually arguing for the
right to have conversations with your
kids
about sexual issues in secret
telling those kids don't tell your
parents
so this is happening are you
homeschooling
no do you want me
no because i found a school that won't
put up with it
and so that's where my kids go but let's
just take that conversation out of the
classroom shall we let's go to a public
park and your kids are playing over by
the monkey bars and a couple of adults
walk up and start showing them those
books with those pictures and having
that conversation with them what would
happen to those adults in a republic
park they would be arrested arrested and
hauled off to jail so if you look on the
american bar association when it goes
into uh the word grooming which is the
big word right now which is accurate in
my opinion it says and seventh circuit
court of appeals actually actually has
this perfect please go look it up
that
um
it is not a defense to say that you are
putting explicit pornographic or obscene
material in front of a child under the
guise of education it is it has already
been stated it has already been
solidified you do not get to hide behind
the veil of of education and that
shields you from something that outside
the school would be considered a felony
well this doesn't work that way so that
this game they're playing the only way
you short circuit that is at some point
parents are going to have enough of it
they're going to go you know what did
you show this to my kid all right turn
around put your hands behind let's take
it to uh the workplace i think it was
robbie starbuck who tweeted this
if you if you talk to another co-worker
about what these teachers are talking
about you would be sued for sexual
harassment yeah that's absolutely right
down right i mean because
these books some of them have shown
relatively graphic images i wouldn't
they're like descriptive
instructional
pictorials
if you went to the workplace take a look
at this book
they'd be like okay i'm going to the
boss the boss is going to be like i'm
letting you go
why are you showing these images but in
the school to children they're arguing
it's okay
under the guise of education what i'm
telling you is that's already been
established there's people have already
tried to use that defense in the highest
courts in our land and they were not
upheld well people need to go after
these teachers and file suits file
charges whatever they have to do
absolutely on top of that another thing
that people are failing to acknowledge
here is that one of the core elements of
grooming is trying to separate the child
from their parents so by definition
having secret conversations with
children especially secret conversations
about sexuality is grooming and i think
everything you just said a moment ago
was put very beautifully and so many
people in this country feel that way and
i think the left is going to start to
realize that they've really woken asleep
and sleeping giant because they're
completely incapable of understanding
other perspectives all they know and
understand is obedience to the party
line and loyalty
to
their sick set of principles and what
their ideological allies tell them to
believe
i think many of them don't have close
familial relationships which is part of
why statistically they actually are more
likely to experience mental health
issues and so they can't comprehend the
bonds that exist between good and
healthy families they have no idea
what's coming their way if they continue
to push on this well i think
if if you go back in time we were
talking about several hundred years ago
where the dad's armed maybe he's got a
single shot you know flintlock or
something like that or a sword or a
knife or something because you never
know you've got to defend yourself your
friends your family
people without families were much less
likely to survive
that's just humans are social beings our
families and our tribes are how we
survived and that's why we have such a
strong social desire to be a part of
this the culture and the tribe because
if you weren't you didn't you didn't
survive
we now have an expanding
society of family-less individuals
they have some friends they hang out
they're in their 30s they're not
relationships they they're they're
single they live in apartments
i i got to say i don't think people
these people would survive the actual
wilderness they're they're a product of
the good times we've created the
security and the safety that allows this
individual ultra individualist
you know i guess lifestyle probably also
a bunch of drug addicts on adderall
prozac who knows legalize
pharmaceuticals so they're like
distorted and aren't able to understand
love with their mother you know it comes
from like well i didn't get along with
her to begin with and like come on guys
i'm just assuming a type of person but
there's a lot of legalized drugs out
there that people are on well i mean
also statistically we know that children
that come from two parent homes fare
better than children who don't they have
absolutely destroyed and gutted the
family it's been a very long standing
project on the left because they can't
have competing power structures and they
know that good
tightly knit families that genuinely
love and care for each other and have a
strong sense of loyalty and parents who
will legitimately protect their children
solve the problems that the state claims
it needs to be in a position to solve
though it never solves them well it
usually ends up creating more problems
than it's addressing
but the point is they're not going to
stop right like they see your connection
to your family as a threat like it is a
threat to their way of life and what
they view is what's necessary for their
survival they're not going to sound like
we have to stop them is the point
they're not going to stop themselves let
me give you guys a white pill i don't
know that that's that's the optimism
right
the the for sure the one that means
things are not so bad black pill is the
end of the white all right let me let me
let me tell you guys what i think is
coming
i think the future is going to be
more conservative than uh this country's
been and maybe like 70 or 80 years for
one simple reason
it has nothing to do with people waking
up to politics it has nothing to do with
young people being based
has everything to do with the fact that
the left does not have children
and if they do get pregnant they are
substantially more likely to abort their
children kill their baby
so
back in uh the early 2000s conservatives
were having about two kids for every two
parents so they were st it was it was
stable
liberals were having 1.7 kids so
typically a family would have one kid
maybe two
now we see in the polls
that
gen z is is a tad bit more conservative
than millennials but millennials and gen
z are still relatively progressive
compared to gen xs and boomers
what happens
in 20 years from today the birth rates
collapsed
but conservatives still have a lot of
kids maybe less on average than before
but way more than liberals
if liberals if the left can't
indoctrinate children in schools
they cease to exist within maybe 40
years exactly it's necessary for their
survival you know what happened when the
wrong immigration when the roman empire
failed and all the slaves were basically
when the roman slave system ended a
bunch of those people went out to the
farms and started working for the
farmers and became their workers uh it's
more nuanced than that and i would
highly recommend um looking into this
because if this hap if this really if
the economy fails and all these people
come out of the cities these liberal
weirdos that don't have families or
whatever they're going to be looking for
work and they're going to be basically
put down i'm going to put on the farm to
get to work and they're going to be
overseen and then they're going to be
you paying whatever you want at that
point do you think they're going full
enough to use on a farm well no no no no
i i gotta disagree bro like there's a
lot of people in cities who could come
and do basic farm work but
i tell the story all the time
let me ask you john uh you remember
occupy wall street i imagine sure
directed by wall street a bunch of land
was granted farmland was granted to
occupy wall street and so a large a
bunch of these these young people were
like i want to get off the grid i want
to be responsible for myself sustainable
and not be a part of the you know carbon
dioxide
corporate fossil fuel economy so they
went to this farm to be totally off the
grid sustainable how long do you think
my friend made it
uh i would say
halfway through his first callus
wherever that came
halfway like my fingers
went through his first blister two weeks
that's about that's about that's your
first kick blister so i asked my friend
two weeks later you're back
and they said it sucked i woke up at 6
am and i worked until 11 p.m yeah i
never had time to do anything it was
just work work work if you want to eat
you got to work then you had breakfast
and you worked again then you had lunch
and you worked again you had dinner and
i was like that's what survival sounds
like right yeah yeah yo these people
yeah but when the owner of the house has
rifles and you're in a fenced in area
and there's nowhere to get out and you
you chose to be there because you need
food like i'm saying we might be on
track to see another serfdom rise in
this country look you're you're you're
not going to be able to take entitled
gaunt millennials i'm not saying
everybody's going to make it either
that's a good point then because some
there's a lot of people that says of
course they're capable you know i i i
don't think they're as skilled or as
learned as people in the countryside
when it comes to basic country things
like the things i've learned just you
know moving out of the cities over the
past several years it's like oh wow i
didn't know that we got chives growing
in the backyard everywhere you just walk
up you pick them you rinse them off you
eat them i'm like i don't even know what
you can or can't eat but the people out
here are like oh here's what you can't
eat here's what you can eat they can
just tell me right away so if if one day
the roads just
the roads were gone and it was like
you're only gonna get food which you can
find
they'd make it i'd be in serious trouble
so people in cities there's a lot of
smart people in cities but they're not
going to know the first thing about how
you you grow crops you know what we did
last year remember those tomatoes we
planted yeah we planted all the tomatoes
at once
and then what happened i'm sad you get a
lot of tomatoes and then you run out of
tomatoes yeah yeah we have like 80
tomatoes you can go and they get run
exactly do you know how to can
no oh you got to learn how to go in man
we we do present man we can learn how to
keep this this is going to be our party
while we're out here you're just
partying
i'm going to tell you where we're at
but we we make preserves that's good i
got them very similar it's very similar
to that you just put tomatoes in it next
time there you go or potatoes or
whatever thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time